Aujourd'hui, je vais vous parler de fourmis
Les tout petits insectes, et de leur nid.
Malgré leur tout petit cerveau,
(en fait, on parle plutôt de ganglions cérébroïdes),
elles sont capables de construire
de véritables cathédrales...
... de terre, évidemment.
Et figurez-vous qu'elles font ça sans plan ni architecte
Balèze !
Une équipe de scientifiques de Toulouse
et de Nantes a enfin réussi à expliquer
le génie bâtisseur de Lasius Niger,
la fourmi noire de nos jardins.
Pour comprendre exactement à quoi
ressemble une fourmilière
avec ses piliers, ses voûtes,
ses galeries,  ses dortoirs...
Les chercheurs ont mis un nid de fourmis
dans un scanner d'hôpital.
Et ça a donné ce modèle 3D.
Ensuite ils ont étudié de très près comment les fourmis se débrouillent pour bâtir les piliers d'un même étage.
OK maintenant ils savent à quoi
ça ressemble dans la nature.
La deuxième étape,
c'est de simuler la construction du nid.
L'idée est de construire un nid virtuel
à partir de fourmis virtuelles.
Les chercheurs ont reproduit les comportements simples des vrais fourmis,
dans ces fourmis virtuelles.
Jusqu'à obtenir des structures comparables
à celles observées dans la nature.
Et c'est comme ça qu'ils ont découvert
la recette simple,
suivie par chaque fourmi, pour construire le nid.
Prenez une boulette de terre.
Ajoutez une pincée de phéromones.
Ce sont un peu comme des odeurs, en quelque sorte.
Ensuite, posez la boulette là où vous
sentez déjà de la phéromone.
Et répétez l'opération une dizaine de milliers de fois.
Et voilà !
La fameuse phéromone qui avait été
ajoutée aux boulettes
indique aux fourmis de poursuivre la construction.
Si la phéromone s'évapore, la construction s'arrête
et les fourmis vont travailler ailleurs.
En plus clair, s'il fait sec, par exemple,
la phéromone va s'évaporer rapidement
et les fourmis vont construire moins de piliers.
Les chambres seront donc plus grandes.
Les fourmis seront plus nombreuses
à pouvoir s'y regrouper
et elles conserveront mieux l'humidité.
Malin !
Ce qu'il faut imaginer, c'est que le nid de fourmis est constamment en train d'être démonté et remonté.
Il sera donc toujours parfaitement
adapté à l'environnement,
qu'il fasse sec ou humide.
Et tout ça grâce à des règles très simples,
mais...
ne soyons pas condescendant.
Ça reste quand même un immense travail...
... un travail de fourmis !
Et si tu as honte de mes blagues, abonne-toi !